I don't wanna have a label I want to
have a legacy
what Davy was a villain it's my father
teeth you should feel fulfilled and
antagonist but it's too mean that
strikes me as exciting it's a very
conscious effort for me to do something
that challenges me every year you give
me anything you learn me to paint the
walls of the studio I'll do the best
damn painting job you've ever seen
she's an actress singer film producer
philanthropist and winner of the mist
world 2,000 pages she's one of India's
highest paid actresses and one of the
nation's most popular celebrities in
2016 time named her one of the 100 most
influential people in the world
she's Priyanka Chopra and here's my take
on her top 10 rules for success rule
number four is my personal favorite and
I'm curious to figure which one you guys
like the best also as Priyanka is
talking if she says something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I don't want to be called an actor I
don't want to be called a star I don't
wanna have a label I want to have a
legacy I want to be known as someone who
has goals and achieves and whatever they
might be wherever they might be I want
to be limitless I want to break
stereotypes I want to go where no matter
woman has gone before and it might be a
scary path and it might be a path that
no one's taken but at least it'll be
just mine
I had the worst self-esteem when I was a
kid I was made fun of because the way I
talked we're because of where I came
from I was made fun of on every level
and the only way you can change that is
setting goals for yourself and saying I
will be the best version of me when I
was 18 and I started doing movies I gave
myself a year and a half and I said if I
don't if I sense that I'm not good at
what I'm doing and I don't see something
opening up for me I'm gonna go back to
college I always had a plan B I still
always have a plan B and that's what I
always tell young people you know life
doesn't end it just keeps moving you
have to put your blinkers on and find
what you do best and just keep moving
America suddenly sat up and said oh this
is a great business module you want to
take an international superstar and put
them into something and that just
elevates the public because today it's
not about domestic entertainment sure
yeah it's so now everyone wants that but
the women because we are beautiful that
you are and the exotic beautiful Indian
girl it's it's an easier place and
easier fit it's an easier fit I mean
I've gone to the left and decided never
to do it because I did a show which is
on my shoulders I'm doing a movie which
I'm not the side chick I'm the main
villain of the movie you know um which
is a different like who day B was a
villain it's my first date he was being
fulfilled and antagonist but it's to
mean that strikes me as exciting I don't
like being conventional but I was trying
to put into that box so much that was
the first place I was put into all the
movies that came to me was that in fact
Baywatch I was being spoken to for
another part but this was just an was
written for a man I got told the last
time so I like my terms a little bit but
the exotic you know gorgeous pretty girl
in amazing clothes is so the fit of
where people tried to put me and I hope
that doesn't happen to anyone else
coming in and out because if she's one
of the four
so I feel like on the phone
typical let me just lay down the rules
yeah no no everyone can do what they
want we need to stand as a force to
reckon with because I industry is that
our industry is is one of the most
prolific in the world and we need to not
be afraid to stand our ground on our
feet and say I'm not settling and I hope
that Indian talent comes there and do
that and I hope me being in the position
of position that I am in can give them
the confidence to do it I've never known
my life without movies I don't know what
that would be like and and now that I'm
doing music to in the last I mean I've
made an album I have almost 40 songs
ready in the last two years and I
finished eight movies so I've been able
to do for a woman where's where's your
cape sorry what's going on you do you
sleep I do I do but I do work every day
I love I love what I do and I have two
careers that I have to handle right now
and I don't want to give up on either
one of them and I don't think I need do
you feel like if you don't work you will
crazy I know my guillotine don't worry I
feel like I don't know Bjelica I have
been working like this since I was 17 I
don't know how to do anything else and I
haven't found a reason to want to take a
break yet if you know what I mean
my name is Alex Parrish protecting our
country had always been my dream
Quantico was my first audition I knew I
had to go in to this room and read these
lines in front of all these people but I
was so nervous before I went in so I
went to the bathroom I remember before I
went in I looked in the mirror and it's
so stupid in please
but I talk to myself and I said what's
wrong with you you've played the most
difficult characters in in in the most
complicated movies tossed my hair a
little bit felt great and what huh did
my bit and got the job as an actor do
you have any lines in your head in terms
of what you will do when you want to
yeah nudity for sure I would for sure
like never also I'm I play bold paths
but I don't like a lot of skin show I do
not explain it like in Ezra I was always
in pants suits but the intensity in the
part was sexual I don't have to dress it
you don't have a dress provocative yeah
I mean I do it for a magazine cover here
and there because it's glamorous and
it's pretty good like the reason one of
the big reasons I did the show with ABC
was because they're Disney so there's
only that much for American standards
that we can do on the show which is
pretty much as much as indie films
there's a difference between wearing a
bikini and a bra you know and I'm indeed
enough I understand that so and I want
to those lines are important to me it's
a very conscious effort for me to do
something that challenges me every year
I do one of those but I also do those
where I can put my hair down and just
the pretty I'm a girl I love doing it
I love blockbuster hindi movies it's my
favorite genre film whether it's in
Hollywood or in Bollywood you take me
for an x-men I would much rather go see
that then I would see a film which tells
me a serious story I'm that audience
yeah sometimes I feel as an actor I
don't get pushed and challenged as much
but you can't always be doing the same
thing I and I like the Will Smith's way
of doing movies you do these big movies
with big money and
big budgets and their commercial and
their successful when you look hard and
you look great and then you do that so
you have to be able to balance both very
few actors get to do it and I'm very I'm
glad that I'm part of that elite group I
don't consider myself a singer I don't
consider myself an actor I consider
myself an achiever okay you give me
anything
you'll dare me to paint the walls of the
studio I'll do the best damn painting
job you've ever seen
okay that's how I've always been I
didn't know I was gonna be an actress
yeah I know I was gonna be a musician
but now whatever opportunities I get I
try and turn them too and let's see what
will happen sure I do the hard work is
something I know I can damn well do okay
so I do that okay but ho gaya great name
wha
alright I'll try something else but I
want to expand myself as an entertainer
as a performer whether that's music
whether it's TV whether it's films
whether that's production anything it is
now franca eight o'clock you just
finished shooting and now you're heading
dope on I'm adding to the launch of my
yes Matt the magazine which is W
Magazine is having a party for the
launch of its Royals issue so I'm on
their covers
um so I'm heading there now yes look
like [ __ ] like you're feeling a kill me
moment how do you guys never the debate
on that's what people don't think I've
ever talked that's exactly so how do you
do this how do you will yourself into
not being giant he's only because all
the stuff that I have to prove is what I
need to do I don't have time for
necessarily the two continents
so it's you know Mike word is my bond
it's my commitment and I unprofessional
that that's my inherent nature is that
you know you just I you have to keep
working if you commit it to something so
you're tired but when you step out of
the sky it's gonna be the million dollar
smile yeah no no no that's the thing I
think you know my mom used to say this
to me um as a woman no one should see
the chinks in her arm
because it's only your own where we are
strong because we have the ability as
women to to be able to hold on to a lot
of emotion and a lot of a lot of things
that are thrown at us we just have to
remember that you know don't let the
world see your weakness the most
beautiful thing about having dreams is
that it's in your hands how big your
dreams become and this film taught me
that I've come here only to introduce
you to the idea of saying that no one
can tell you that your dream is too
small or your dream cannot come true or
your dream cannot be allowed because
you're a girl because you're a boy
because you look a certain way or
because because you come from a certain
place I am NOT even northeastern and I
am playing mary calm I mean who would
have thought that I am extremely honored
to be sitting in front of all of you
wonderful wonderful really smart people
and talking to you about my dream which
came true doing this film don't be
afraid to dream guys because they do
come true they really do when I was very
young I was 19 and I was doing first few
movies I remember that a producer just
said well she can't work it out it's
fine we'll just cause someone else girls
are replaceable subconsciously it really
worked on my mind and I started picking
up parts which were strong which were
not just the damsel in distress waiting
for someone to rescue me now 13 15 years
later the movies that I do
I'm irreplaceable thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because
Gopi Acharya Albert pronounced it ok
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I made a profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what the Priyanka
say that really had a meaningful impact
on you what was your favorite rule and
why what did you learn most from this
video please leave it in the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally want to give a quick
shout out to Scott J Weaver senior Scott
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really really really means a lot
to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon